je suis chef d'entreprise dans le
marketing digital non tu vends des news
à 15 balles sur sur 1000 arrête
[Applaudissements]
quel immeuble quel immeuble quel
immeuble moi je te le disque tu es en
train de me décevoir moi je te le dis
vraiment c'est honte c'est vrai tu es en
train de me décevoir ton discours est
une misogyne
ketchup poser est-ce que tu trouves son
discours misogyne
pourquoi tu l'as pas dit avant
non mais elle alors Ruby juste au rugby
non sans charrier là est-ce que tu fais
des photos que je fais des news ce que
tu fais des nudes
c'est plus possible c'est quoi c'est non
mais non franchement
non
ça va plus du tout on va droit dans le
mur vos discours toi Guillaume
franchement tu me déçois
pourquoi pourquoi ça a pas pourquoi
pourquoi
on peut s'habiller comme on veut
on est censé être dans un pays libre moi
maintenant si j'ai envie de me pointer à
7h du matin dans un café ou un
restaurant
ou un restaurant
habillé sexy je peux m'habiller sexy
où je suis en France et voilà moi voilà
mais est-ce que aujourd'hui pour comment
tu gagnes comment tu gagnes ta vie elle
vend des immeubles
comment tu les as acheté rubis c'est
avec tout ce que tu fais sur les réseaux
tu as gagné beaucoup d'argent
il faut dire la vérité les gens qui
posent dans des voitures de luxe sur
Instagram dans des hôtels de luxe ne
gagne pas leur argent en achetant des
immeubles et en ayant des chefs
d'entreprise comment s'appelle tes
salariés c'est qui tes salariés ce genre
de discours que justement nous les
femmes on se fait harceler dans la rue
ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que moi je
peux plus me promener en mini-jupe ça
n'a rien à voir non mais ça n'a rien à
voir
justement c'est à avoir et ça veut dire
que moi je peux pas me promener en mini
d'ailleurs ce soir
c'est même pas une question de femme en
fait si c'est un homme c'est ce serait
pareil le problème c'est que pardon mais
vous exaspérez tout le monde vous prenez
pour des gens importants des grandes
dames des grands messieurs de la société
en réalité vous ne faites rien vous ne
créez rien vous n'avez aucun talent vous
ne créez aucune valeur vous ne
travaillez pas voilà et tout ce que vous
faites c'est exactement et pardon mais
quelqu'un qui vous regarde sur les
réseaux sociaux je dors deux heures par
nuit énormément
[Applaudissements]